- We need to talk about the
new season of Magnum P.I.
So what can you tell us about
what's happening right now?
- The new season is a lot of the same.
There's a lot of action, a lot of fun.
There's this very strong
family sort of quality
to all the characters on the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, I mean, it's kind of
all the stuff that we expect,
but I also direct an episode.
- Oh, is that something
you're interested in doing?
- I directed one last-
I love it.
- Oh, that's cool.
- I love it.
It's this really kind of interesting thing
where as an actor, Jay
Hernandez, the individual,
has to kind of stay in his lane,
but as a director you
can kind of go outside
and play outside the
boundaries a little bit.
So that's one
thing that I love about it
- It's interesting 'cause
I've never had any
interest like behind that.
Like I've just never, it's
just never pulled at me.
- Mm-hmm.
- And it's interesting, like,
I feel like it's actors
a lot of times too.
Like, y'all (indistinct) musicians,
it's like actors really like to be a part
of the whole story, not
just their one characters.
I find that a lot on the couch.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think what it is, is like,
there's just a type of freedom
that you have as a director
that you don't necessarily
have as an actor.
- Yeah.
- Because, you know, you're
just not afforded the liberty
to play a a million different
characters sometimes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, like whatever they think I am,
it's like I gotta kind
of stay in that lane.
- [Kelly] I hate that when
people get typecasted.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What's the craziest stunt though?
Cuz it's action packed, So like what's-
- [Jay] There's a lot of action.
- Do you like the action?
Doing all that?
- I love it. I love it.
- Okay.
- Yeah. I absolutely love it.
I don't love it when I have,
you got two-pound burrito
and then gotta' sprint on top of a rooftop
(Kelly laughing)
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Don't love that.
But I've done everything on the
show, car stunts, like guns,
like chasing people, fight
scenes, all this stuff.
But one of the coolest things
was in the episode I directed last season.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was, we were doing
this underwater stuff
and it was just like this easy shot of me,
kind of like floating through the ocean
looking for some sunken vessel and-
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- And well, that's not
the coolest part about it.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So I'm like probably 60-feet
under the surface of the ocean.
And the coordinator stunt guy,
he tells me to turn
around and I turn around,
and there was a pod of like 60 dolphins
that were-
- [Derek] Amazing.
- swimming by and you see like the little,
like the little baby ones.
- [Derek] The baby ones are the best.
- They were playing around-
- Yeah.
- with the older ones.
- [Kelly] That's magical.
- It was like surreal,
magical. It was crazy.
And it was, it felt
like I really understood
that they were a family.
- [Derek] Mm-hmm.
- It was the strangest experience,
but it was just beautiful.
- I mean, you, we don't pause enough.
Like that's a moment that not
really anyone's gonna have.
- Yeah, no, and, and-
- Do you know what I'm
saying, how special is that?
- It was work for me, you know.
Like I was I was getting paid to be there.
- [Derek] Yeah.
Like I would pay for that experience, but-
- Yeah, but nobody gets
that kind of experience
just out in the wild.
That's like really cool.
- [Jay] Yeah, it was beautiful.
- I can't imagine the energy off of that.